have a plan but be ready to change it
any time I think you know one of the big
questions is how do you juggle three
YouTube channels everyone has a chance
to grab this attention it's just a
matter of like holding it for a longer
period it's becoming harder and harder
you're a business owner content creator
if you got a team to manage and then a
family to run and then selfcare to take
care of yourself what what have you
learned about being a parent and also
being a business owner and a content
creator as far as tips staying sane
getting it all done
so what does it really take to make it
as a content creator today we're going
to be learning from someone who has over
10 million subscribers across her
channels but of course she didn't start
there and so we're going to be hearing
her story learning her tips as well as
discussing some things like raising
Venture Capital as a creator that
actually is possible and what are some
of the Innovations happening there what
are the opportunities for non-english
channels and what are some of the tips
for parents that are trying to juggle
business or their jobs and content
creation so many topics with Marina
Millo woohoo I say right thank you for
having me Silicone Valley girl yeah
Silicone Valley Girl linga Marina Marina
multiple personalities multiple
personalities so Greatful to have you on
the think media podcast you were on the
show U you were at Grow video live
virtually during the pandemic three
years ago three years ago crushed it
you're doing so many cool things in
entrepreneurship as a content creator
for people that are just meeting you
though what are you up to go a little
back a little bit when did you start and
what are you up to these days yeah I
actually started back in 2014 my story
is I'm Russian was born and raised in
Russia started a company together with
my husband to help students study abroad
uh started growing this company but we
had hard hard time raising in Russia and
like growing internationally so we're
like okay we need to raise money abroad
but again it was hard and I thought okay
let us try and get an MBA in the US I
heard they were giving out scholarships
to International students and I got the
scholarship uh to study in John's H
Hopkins and University of Florida for my
MBA uh but we also got an offer from 500
startups in silcon Valley this is how we
ended up in silcon Valley and this is
how I started my channel because I took
my GMAT and I was like okay well first
of all I discovered YouTube as a
platform when I when I was getting ready
for my exams I was like oh my God a
completely different platform with all
of these amazing videos I want to
participate too so I took my GMAT and I
came back came back home and I recorded
my first video how to take GMAT that was
9 years ago that was in Russian and
yesterday my Russian Channel hit 2
million followers wow and so we moved to
the US uh I started I continued making
content in Russian but I I was like okay
we're in the US now how about I start in
English so I started my channel called
lingua Marina which is now at almost 8
million followers and I'm inspiring
people to learn English to change their
life with English so it's English for
non-english native speakers but I also
talk a lot about American culture and
then I realized that my American friends
are not consuming my content because
it's all about like how to speak English
so I started silcon Valley Girl a
Channel about life in silcon Valley wow
so three different channels and then do
you have multiple businesses I have uh
well basically two companies one company
is the one that we started back then uh
we raised Venture Capital it's a study
broad booking platform and also online
education platform so you can learn
languages uh by taking online courses
and another company just manages
whatever I'm doing as a Creator my media
company gotcha and lingua Marina is that
that is that what's connected to the
company or is it separate it's kind of
connected just because I do a lot of
promotion for my company but it's a
separate entity gotcha that's amazing
and so I think you know one of the big
questions is how do you juggle three
YouTube channels yeah yeah it's a great
question I have a team this is like the
most helpful thing ever I have amazing
people who help me with scripting who
look through the videos who edit them
who post them like they do all of that
I'm just in front of the camera so
they're super helpful and also I had a
schedule but before 2023 I had a very
strict schedule I wanted to do one long
video each week for each Channel and
then three shorts for each chn so that's
like 12 videos a week have you been
staying consistent with that and I was
super consistent in 2022 but I almost
burned out because I really wanted to
travel and I was like oh I want to see
my parents in Thailand but that means I
can't really create content there
because it's too hot like it's not where
you create content for my channels um
specifically so I thought okay I came up
with the schedule but it's me who came
up with the schedule no one is forcing
me to release that many videos and so
now it's more like okay if I'm in the
mood I will create videos so I think I'm
down to like four to five videos a week
counting shorts counting shorts yeah
yeah yeah that's amazing and how many
team members are working on the content
creation side of things I would say
around five I have a I have two editors
I have a YouTube manager I have someone
who helps me with thumbnails and I have
like when I say YouTube manager is
basically someone who helps me with
scripts and posting and I have like a
substitute YouTube manager but I also
have a team who works on my courses and
a team who works on my brand deals yeah
okay I need to probably count them so
all together they're 35 I don't like it
like we're 35 people yeah we're going to
see how we we can optimize things
because you know I when I was running
lingu trip it was like over 60 people
like our language learing company and I
realize I can't do it because I'm not
the best manager in the world I freak
out when people are unhappy and I I
freak out when people don't follow my
instructions so I freak out a lot so my
husband took over and he's the CEO he's
running it he's a lot more stable a lot
better coo than I am but now the same
thing is happening with my personal team
I'm like I want this person that person
now there are too many people I think
yeah wow that's uh quite the Empire and
um I'm curious some of the lessons
you've learned from successful YouTube
videos that you've posted you've posted
a lot of videos so some do better than
others and probably for a portion of our
audience your English Channel so con
valley girl um is probably one of the
most relevant channels to learn from
what are some of the lessons you've
learned from your most viral videos uh
your top viewed video of all time is on
profitable business ideas it got 3.3
million views but the my my most popular
video most watched video is my short
about washing a car in California how
much it costs to wash a Tesla in
California 42 million views I did not
expect this and this is what you learn
from these video like you don't expect
with shorts things can go wild that was
like a mini Vlog it was my first time
Wasing a Tesla and I was trying to
figure out where's this neutral mode
because if if you've driven Tesla it's
like goes either up or down and neutral
is a small small button on the screen
somewhere and I was like oh my God how
do I wash my car so and people were
laughing at me basically so one of the
things is shorts you've been finding the
most views with shorts and it's a vlog
you you filmed it and kind of edited it
later structured it not just to throw it
out there I would I would create b-roll
when I'm on set or like in in the wild
and then I will come back home and make
a mini Vlog out of it with a voice voice
over gotcha okay um how about long form
and that's what I was looking at was
some of your long forms what are some of
the lessons you learned from you know
most profitable business ideas I noticed
you turned this into a series have you
found yeah cuz it was performing so well
but again it's like it's so weird with
YouTube 5 years ago every everyone was
making those videos like business ideas
or like productivity videos and they
were booming these days something
different I think people are already fed
up with those videos so I made that
video I don't even remember what
inspired me I was just because I live in
silon Valley I see so many people trying
so many different things and because we
moved to the US and I had experience uh
living in Europe you know just
experiencing different cultures I really
one of the best things to be in the US
as well like I think one of the ideas
there was how do we make
healthy food outside San Francisco in LA
because when you're driving from San
Francisco to LA like gas station food is
oh my God you can't really eat it it's
not healthy and so I was like let's
create a vending machine with Organic
farmer and I think they appear like 5
years later I see them in in in the
airport so it was just like I want to
inspire people to do something that I
miss in the US and uh this is how this
series came up um how it came up with
the series yeah what tips do you have uh
if somebody asks you and they see all
your success from starting YouTube and
they're thinking about starting a
channel uh what advice do you give them
stay consistent and experiment that's it
that's it you you just try and try and
try you try 20 different videos and like
sometimes we like okay I'm putting out
10 pieces of content there it's all the
same like if it's all the same it's not
going to work you have to try role plays
or I don't know do comedy like just go
out there and try different things so
you're you mentioned before you're kind
of evolved in a little bit in your brand
how has your brand evolved you mentioned
you're getting into fashion and so uh
what is kind of your thinking there and
what it means to reinvent yourself or
evolve as a Creator yeah so because um I
rais a venture around as a Creator they
so investors when they invest in
creators or startups anything they're
betting that they can to invest in 10
creators and one of them is going to
become the Jeff basos of creators so
what is J basos of Creator like who is
that person and when I think about it
these are people who are getting big
contracts right who are making like tens
of millions of dollars but not just
because they're posting content like you
can't get to the L Celebrity level just
as a content creator you need to be a
media person like I was on the panel
with Patrick Star yesterday and he he
said he got 400 million views on his
YouTube channel and at the same time he
sells millions of item items of his
makeup at Sephora I have two billion
views on my channels but I don't sell
that like this is not what I'm doing
doing business-wise like and if I go to
Sephora I would probably fail right now
so being a media person and being a
Creator um are two different things and
this is what I'm trying to figure out
next how do you go from just being a
Creator when everything that you do just
depends on you making content versus how
do I become this celebr whatever you
call Media person where companies create
content about you because you're
exciting you're interesting they want to
see you so Patrick has a really bright
personal I'm trying to figure out what
is that for me how are you incorporating
some of that new content is it going
into some of your videos what channel is
that going on or is it also other
platforms are you embracing other
platforms it's going everywhere it's
just I Am shifting like with education
or business I think the maximum number
of views you can get like consistently
like a million is really good yeah
people who are in entertainment or like
lifestyle they get 10 million views
consistently 20 million views
consistently so I'm trying to even like
for educational stuff I just recorded a
collab with Leo gonzale do you know the
he's like one of my favorite creators
right now he's so fun so we we did like
basic English versus American English I
say a phrase he says a phrase so it's
fun it's not like I'm teaching something
like grammar it's just just fun to watch
for everyone Americans I did a a similar
collab with an Australian Creator like I
am trying to bring it uh into the
entertainment World kind of so that
everyone can understand the takeaway uh
if I'm understanding too is education
also has a lid on it at some point yeah
education business investment like it's
it's a niche but if you start tapping
into entertainment you
can that l a lot higher and even your
core thing of helping with language and
teaching English you make that
entertaining you bring collaboration
into it it can have a whole greater
level of reach absolutely like dualingo
their strategy is just mindblowing have
you seen their their mascot so they
they're one of the top companies
crushing it on social media because they
came up with this Green Owl which was
their mascot uh for a while and now
they're just following Trends with it
millions of views every single short
there's social media person she was here
last year and she was the reason I came
to VidCon because I wasn't speaking uh
last year and she's like 23 24 and so
dual lingo is this world phenomenon now
because they're just you know everybody
knows dolingo things to Tik toks and
everybody and they see how people start
using up more and more because they are
targeted bombarded with those videos
they're recommended everywhere you
mentioned you raised Venture and for
people that are not familiar with
Silicone Valley lingo can you explain
what that is and even what that meant
and if that's an opportunity for others
yeah so it's definitely an opportunity
for others I met a couple more people
who are raised from the same same
Venture company it's called slow
Ventures they are investing in creators
and again they're betting that out of 10
creators you know some will become uh
huge and I like that it's very silon
Valley Style and what I mean by that is
that they give me Capital like when I
was talking to them they're like we have
no control over your content you can do
whatever you want if you decide to stop
tomorrow there's nothing we can do about
it like this is it's up to you so I have
all the freedom in the world to do
whatever I want with the money to do
whatever I want with my content they
will never come and say like hey Marina
stop posting this this is inappropri
whatever like there's no say but they're
actually super helpful whenever like I
have anything I I just go and ask so
this is the Silicon Valley sale of
investing at early stage they give you a
lot of freedom and you do whatever you
feel is best for your career yeah wow
and if somebody so that's a company they
could look up would you encourage people
to Google it collaborate network if they
wanted to explore this absolutely slow
Ventures and I think they have a
newsletter for creators called slow
upload so subscribe and yeah I I feel
like this is like I would personally
invest in the current batch of like
Stanford graduates like investing in
people is this New Concept which totally
makes sense because we invest especially
early stage investing we do not invest
in a company we invest in the founder
who would think it's going to take this
to the next level so why not invest them
and then is that ultimately for a
portion of the IP the intellectual
property for a portion of ownership in
your brand for a period of time
definitely it's like a revenue uh
Revenue share agreement uh for a period
of time uh oh sorry profit profit
sharing agreement yeah yeah you have
three channels and one is in English
you have basically kind of a vlog
Lifestyle Channel in Russian just cross
2 million subscribers a lot of people do
ask okay if I'm
bilingual um or what video what language
should I do on my videos and should I
upload two different languages two
different languages should I upload two
different languages on the same channel
no no no never never never separate them
and yes please embrace all of your
languages all of your backgrounds
because it's just amazing how like it's
it's different my Russian audience they
are so attached to me kind of because
I've been blogging for 9 years yeah and
a lot of them grew up with me and um I
also feel like if you're in the US all
of the a lot of countries in the world
look up to the US and they want to know
what it's like to be here so yeah I have
a lot of I know a lot of creators who
Vlog in like English and Japanese
English and Spanish if they Vlog in in
both though are you saying they upload
on the the same channel no no no no two
separate channels so they Vlog twice you
do yeah this is what I do so with shorts
it's a lot easier cuz again b-roll and
then I come back home do separate
voiceovers and I also work with a
startup called allank they do five more
languages for me they do Spanish French
German Portuguese Arabic with dubbing
with with dubbing yeah they use AI is it
your voice no no no no no it's a
different voice it's a different voice
but so is it then generally the Vlog is
a voiceover model which allows it as
opposed to vlogging two camera if you if
you Vlog two camera it's two separate
takes in two languages which I do all
the time and and it's fine okay it's
just it takes twice as long but then you
don't have to go back to the same like
setting you just do the same thing okay
so the reason number one the reason you
don't want to do it is because you could
confuse the algorithm right and if
somebody and ifuse people like if I only
speak English and you start uploading in
Chinese I will just skip skip skip and
then the algorithm learns that it's not
the audience so of course so keep so
keep it focused on the channel now if
you wanted to do multiple channels so
you separate them you're maybe just
doing some clips throughout the day
where you do two languages but then
knowing that other parts of it will just
be is it a lot of voice over and b-roll
typically in your Vlogs no that's that's
only for short so my long video strategy
is actually so for lingua Marina I would
just do long videos specifically for
that channel because I only talk about
that topic on that channel silicon valy
girl I would sometimes do the same Vlogs
as I do for my Russian Channel but again
they're slightly different okay uh
because for example my latest video is a
notion collab and they specifically
wanted Silicon Valley girl so I just did
a 15minute video showing my templates
English it's yeah and it's not going to
go to to my Russian channel it's it's
different content I got it what do you
think is the opportunity for
non-english-speaking YouTube channels
right now do you think there's a big
Global opportunity yeah it's never been
as easy as in 2023 just because you
don't have to say anything there are so
many Trends where you just do something
and Music Play and that's it you don't
have to say a word in your language
which is cab Kabam is the right way to
pronounce the number one Tik tocker yeah
like he doesn't speak a word in English
but he's the face of Huga boss he's the
face of binance us he's the like he's
everywhere he's the face of Pepsi in La
has a huge billboard doesn't say a word
in English in his videos wow and with AI
and there's a lot of startups that have
that are doing the dubbing that are
dubbing channels and so and I did hear
about some that actually will AI your
voice so it is actually your voice
speaking to different languages which is
just super wild what about in general
some people think okay you've been doing
this since 2014 yeah and now it's 2023
people go oh it's so crowded do you
think it's too late to start YouTube I
don't think so I think it's just the the
concept of a Creator is changing like 20
years ago we have Oprah we had like all
of these people who know today as well
for huge celebrities I think this
opportunity is now almost gone cuz
there's so much content there is so many
people so it's going to be harder and
harder to become that one big celebrity
who's famous for the Next Generation but
I feel you have a really good chance to
be like to be visible because of the
social media algorithm because of how
much time we spent on socials so
everyone has a chance to grab this
attention it's just a matter of like
hold in it for a longer period is
becoming harder and harder one of the
quotes I heard in the industry session
that we're living in a world where
everybody's going to be famous but
nobody's going to know who anybody is
exactly like small
niches Niche Superstars Stu which is
it's okay which is kind of it which the
opportunity becomes it's the Practical
we talk about it a lot where not
everyone's going to be a YouTube
millionaire but the practicality of
earning $50,000 a year on the side or
replacing your other job in some way is
practical if it's a particular you pick
the way you position and I think about I
mean it is kind of wild we have uh
Mary's Nest was just here um when I
spoke at VidCon and we got it was the
first time we met she's 60 was when she
started YouTube she had never posted she
just turned 65 she does cooking videos
she's about to hit a million subscribers
now if you follow her you'd recognize
her but most people would never
recognize her in public you could be
followed by a million people yeah but
you're not you're not also maybe she's
uh maybe her followers are in a
different country
this is what sometimes happen people
like oh I have 10 million views but no
one is approaching me in the street and
they go to Dubai and they can't walk
sure this is also like this phenomenon
because you can be anywhere that's true
it's a global audience yeah yeah um
amazing so you made a video about a
while back about how much YouTube pays
you YouTube specifically now you
probably haven't looked at the numbers
recently but I am curious It's always
people's question specifically like how
much they can earn from ad Revenue how
much does YouTube pay you not much these
days I think it declined for everyone uh
it's 50% less than it was last year wow
so my Russian Channel I think it's like
2K a month my lingua Marina which is
like 8 million so maybe 9k 9 to 12K
depending Silicon Valley girl is also it
fluctuates a lot if a video is like
getting a lot of views but it's also
like 2 to 5K every month it's not not a
lot have you seen that sorry a lot money
in but like for the views that I'm
getting sure cuz people be like yeah
it's a lot of money you add up all those
monies and and there's also a team
behind you that's supporting so that
that's a lot of money for an individual
it's not as much if you're employing
other people are paying Freelancers
exactly so also um my guess is you have
three channels so you get to see
different cpms and RPMs my guess is that
Silicone Valley girl would be the
highest the highest because of the type
of people who watch it and you talk
about things like Tesla which attracts
the Tesla audience well that was a short
so it doesn't really matter but yeah
yeah it's it's typically has a higher
CPM if they're in the US and maybe the
age and economics of the viewers is that
affect you think that affect of course
of course I I think the highest CPM I've
seen was on that channel and it was $72
for a video for for th000 views wow so
it was a video the topic I think it was
something how to create a website
something like very specific very Niche
yeah and uh a lot of people from
Australia we watching in Australia is
like my dear Australians thank you for
watching that is so that is amazing are
you act active on Tik Tok yes what is
your thought of Tik Tok versus YouTube I
think Tik Tok is your shot at becoming a
celebrity like if you're if you're top
1% then you're kab lame Charlie Deo but
if you're average Tik tocker like I am
there is nothing like I don't really
make money there they pay like a dollar
a day uh I don't really get super fans
there like sub subscribers who are who
are in love with uh with my content they
just scroll through my content sometimes
the video goes viral sometimes it
doesn't so I don't I I don't have the
sense of community there um but this is
my experience maybe because you know I'm
always like posting about different
things but I feel like YouTube my
YouTube subscribers are a lot more loyal
to my content well knowing everything
you know now let's say all 10 million
across three channels and all your other
accounts all went to zero but you had
all the skills and all the knowledge
that you have what would be your
approach to starting as a content
creator from scratch what platform or
what would you do first shorts and reals
okay to well because it's pretty much
the same if content goes viral on
YouTube probably will go viral on
Instagram slightly different so
Instagram prefers prefers shorter videos
8 to 10 seconds very visual YouTube is
still The Sweet Spot will be like 50 to
60 second Clips but I feel like they're
also trying to make people create
shorter videos so that you know it's
easier to to start posting so I will
totally do these two platforms because
Instagram because you have stories and
uh stories is this great way to see you
in real time again deeper connection and
YouTube um the algorithm likes your
subscribers and they would actually see
your new videos I love it and so you
would go Instagram and YouTube would be
the play for you yeah Tik Tok it's like
if I can have a person who will just uh
repost all my videos this is what we do
now I don't make Tik Tok specific
content as we land the plane you have
two daughters mhm uh what ages three and
two three and two we have a lot of
families and parents watching this
you're a business owner content creator
you're doing through all kinds of stuff
you got a team to manage and then a
family to run and then self-care to take
care of yourself what what have you
learned about being a parent and also
being a business owner and a content
creator as far as tips staying sane
getting it all done yeah and Al first of
all don't well have a plan but be ready
to change it any time like I've planned
something and then my daughter is sick
so she's staying home so I can't do
anything if she's home I can't work I
have to be with her so it's always like
yes I have a plan but it might change
yeah uh this is the first thing the
second thing it gets easier when they
like if they start daycare then you have
more hours in a day it's still different
um we were lucky cuz my mom stayed with
us when Emily was born her first
daughter so so she really helped me she
would go outside and walk with her and I
will record my videos and we go to Nanny
we like in the past two months we were
just me my husband and I was
bad because they still wake up at night
yeah once they stop waking up at night I
think this is when you when you become
feeling better and I if you can do sleep
training yeah cuz I couldn't I can't
when they start crying cuz sleep
training is like uh let them cry I can't
so they still want to sleep with us they
still wake up in the night yeah we have
a 2 and a half-year-old and a 9month old
oh you had a second baby we have two
boys and um definitely we've learned you
have to be flexible and we are also
learning because we once we had the
second one it restarted again we had
already got one's walking he sleeping in
his own room actually and then we're
like but then we're like oh we're
starting over though you know now we
have another one sleeping with us it's
great that you were able to do that with
the first one I can't like she has to
Emily has to and Lily as well they can't
sleep alone they freak out totally yeah
and and uh but we're learning it's
seasonal and so having the long game as
oppos it could be frustrating in the
moment because you think about what's
the next months or a year but then you
think about multiple years and family is
everything so family is everything
that's true yeah and it goes by fast I'm
reading this book it goes I think it
it's called it goes fast it goes so fast
and like that it does go fast so I'm I
try to appreciate every moment and I'm
here but I'm leaving like my plane is in
3 hours so I can pick them up from
daycare really want to do that yeah
hopefully it's not delayed yeah uh well
so grateful for you and just want to
acknowledge you thanks so for adding so
much value to so many people and taking
time to be on the podcast of course if
people want to check you out do a roll
call of your stuff or anything you're
working on I we'll link it up in the
show notes and so uh follow me on
Instagram I think Instagram is like me
every day in real time yeah and then of
course on Instagram you let people know
about stuff you're doing course stories
new video coming up everything yeah yeah
amazing and so shout that out where is
that what are your Instagram handle
lingua Marina amazing thank you so much
for coming on the thi media podcast
thank you so much for having me and uh
subscribe if you're not subscribed share
it out smash like if you're on YouTube
rate and review if you're on audio talk
soon peace